salut tu en laisses encore les gens
comme ça on s'est pas vu depuis 3 ans
alors fais-moi un vrai câlin
pourquoi tu dors à l'hôtel j'ai un bon
prix parce que je voyage beaucoup et
j'aime les chambres d'hôtel j'avais dit
que je resterai pas longtemps
la bonne mine quand est-ce que tu as
changé de couleur de cheveux ça fait un
an
ok
tu serais au courant si on faisait des
Skype ou des FaceTime ou des trucs comme
ça
comment vont tes soeur depuis la mort de
maman et Maggie est allée à la fac mais
elle a tout arrêté comme ça son première
mais sérieusement tu trouves pas cracher
elle est un peu bizarre elle a dit
qu'elle était déprimée
c'est peut-être plutôt à cause de Nathan
je pourrais aller lui casser la gueule
tu crois pas que je gagnerai contre
Nathan
tu es au courant que je fais une petite
fête chez moi demain soir tu devrais
venir ce serait sympa eric va peut-être
partir demain
c'est difficile d'anticiper j'attends
des coups de fil pour savoir tu étais où
hier soir on peut rejouer demain c'est
pas demain que tu pars je peux changer
mon vol
merci d'avoir sacrifié autant de temps
pour nous ce week-end pourquoi Rachel me
déteste tu prends les choses à l'envers
c'est toi qui me déteste à cause de ça
c'est pas vrai si c'est vrai
maman est morte je crois qu'elle l'a
jamais vraiment digéré est-ce que tu
pourrais faire ça à un autre moment
c'est comme ça
que tu as trouvé que je suis pas l'air
calme
avant tu pensais que j'étais la personne
la plus drôle du monde
ça arrive à tout le monde
tout mon pognon
c'est quoi ton problème
pour une raison qui m'échappe
complètement elle a un petit faible pour
toi ça a marqué l'histoire c'est certain
qui peut dire le contraire
tu vas pas rester encore une nuit
de sentir mieux
[Musique]
si vous voulez tout savoir j'étais parti
en goguer j'avais déjà fait à régler
avec quelques connaissances